même si les chiffres sont alarmants
l'industrie française n'est pas morte
loin de là jean pierre clamadieu bonjour
bonjour à s'y être l'installer vous
c'est le président benji vous publiez
l'europe à venir de l'industrie
française aux éditions du cherche midi
il faut expliquer l'industrie c'est un
peu l'histoire de votre vie vous y fait
toute votre carrière en dirigeants des
grands groupes industriels mais c'est
aussi celle où c'est intéressant une
histoire familiale vous êtes fils de
cheminot et donc vous avez été un petit
peu aux premières loges des vues
l'ascension et le déclin l'industrie
française c'est vrai que j'ai gardé des
souvenirs très forts de mon enfance
alors à la fois le monde cheminot je
pense que la sncf est une belle
entreprise industrielle mais aussi le
début de grandes aventures qui ont
marqué la france je reste dans le
domaine du rail le développement du tgv
mais l'avion le premier vol du concorde
le premier vol d'airbus le premier vol
d'ariane c'est vraiment ses aventures là
qui m'ont convaincu de fait rarement
dans l'ag de gand mais maintenant le tgv
alors ça remonte effectivement mais je
crois que c'est des choses qui ont
marqué nos territoires qui ont marqué
nos villes qui ont marqué d'ailleurs
notre environnement le tgv a refaçonné
l'image de la de la france et est un
outil incroyable airbus est une
fantastique réussite européenne
ariane également et donc je crois que
c'est ses aventures qui m'ont convaincu
de devenir ingénieur et puis
progressivement effectivement au fil des
opportunités de carrière d'avoir la
chance de diriger deux grands groupes de
chimie successifs est aujourd'hui
présidé le conseil jean qu'est ce qui
vous a poussé à écrire ce olivier un
déclic notamment dans le livre on vous
le dit l'envol de space x on est en 2020
et là vous dites on est en train de
rater ouais parce que l'envol de ce pays
6 au fond on pourrait dire passer un
petit peu comme cetc grande aventure que
j'évoquais ces images qui m'ont marqué
ariane concorde ou airbus la différence
d'abord c'est que ce sont des
entrepreneurs américains qui sont à
l'origine de ces de ses aventures et
puis une espèce d'une mise en forme qui
est un peu celle d'une série télévision
et qui je crois ne te donne moins envie
à nos jeunes européens de s'engager dans
cette aventure et effectivement le c'est
un des éléments qui m'a fait dire il
faut rappeler à tout le monde que
l'industrie française c'est vraiment
un des éléments qui fondent notre pays
notre culture l'avenir de notre économie
et qu'il faut l'intégrer dans un
environnement européen après quand on
regarde par donc froidement les chiffres
je sais que vous n'êtes pas fan du de ce
flot de lamentations sur le déclinisme
ambiant sur le déclassement de la france
mais pardon quand on regarde froidement
les chiffres je parle des chiffres
macroéconomiques qu'est ce qu'on a on
perde toujours quasiment des emplois
industriels le niveau de production
industrielle et plus bas qu'avant encore
une fois le co vide et notre déficit
commercial faut se boucher les oreilles
c'est 100 milliards d'euros en rythme
annuel on se dit comme que la situation
mais son envie de rêver de l'industrie
et pas glorieuse pour le dire gentiment
non mais d'abord il faut rêver et c'est
effectivement parce qu'on rencontre des
difficultés qu'il faut rêver et je crois
que sont même rentrés dans les chiffres
le fait de se promener dans des régions
traditionnellement industrielle en
france moi j'étais en poste en région
champagne ardenne au début de début de
ma carrière on voit des paysages qui ont
été marqués par la désindustrialisation
et les chiffres que vous évoquez il
conforte bien sûr ce sentiment mais
c'est le moment de se dire il faut se
réveiller il faut avancer et il faut
sortir d'une forme de déclinisme et
d'une vision un peu passéistes d'une
industrie qu'on aimerait conserver dans
le formol c'est une image que je
reprends aux aidants dans ce livre pour
se dire il faut y aller il faut rêver il
faut avancer il y a devant nous des
opportunités elle commence à avoir des
effets très concret très visible on veut
en parler mais comme en expliquant ce
soit plus d industrialiser que nos
petits voisins européens les gens me
dire la faute aux grands maux aux grands
groupes est ce que je me trompe ou pas
alors probablement probablement la
france a cette particularité d'avoir un
nombre beaucoup plus important que nos
voisins européens de grands groupes qui
sont des leaders mondiaux et six leaders
mondiaux quand ils ont rencontré des
difficultés à la maison et bah ils sont
partis sur d'autres territoires pour
trouver les perspectives de
développement et peut-être plus
facilement que dans d'autres pays dans
lesquels il y avait par exemple en
allemagne un groupe d'entreprises de
taille moyenne qui elle avait un ancrage
territorial fort et je pense
qu'effectivement cette situation joint
peut-être à une à une difficulté qu'on a
dans notre pays de transformer de faire
évoluer parce que l'industrie c'est un
monde qui bouge sans arrêt donc il faut
qu il faut que les entreprises soient
l'affût de ces évolutions et puis s'y
engager
aussi a conduit à une forme de
désindustrialisation à laquelle il faut
j'en suis convaincu aujourd'hui mettre
fin on parle beaucoup de délocalisation
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que quand on
regarde les chiffres les pertes de parts
de marché de la france en matière de
commerce extérieur ces pertes ne se font
pas vis-à-vis de la vie ne se font pas
vis-à-vis de la chine mais vis-à-vis de
nos partenaires européens et là on se
dit est ce que ses rangs preuve de coups
de coût du travail souvent pays là dans
l'industrie le coup travail c'est trop
cher c'est trop élevé les charges
sociales c'est trop élevés notamment ce
qui est vrai quand on se compare à
l'allemagne mais pas que donc je crois
qu'effectivement le coût du travail et
est un sujet les comparaisons que l'on
peut être fait
les comparaisons qui ont pu être entre
la france et l'allemagne le montre cette
problématique très particulier en france
des impôts de production un quart des
impôts que vous des impôts que vous
payez avant même d'avoir commencé à
gagner de l'argent commence à baisser un
petit peu comment c'est absurde il ya eu
un certain nombre de yemma sa tombe de
rupture une difficulté à faire
travailler ensemble l'écosystème
enseignements et en partie enseignement
dur à tout niveau enseignement supérieur
recherche entreprises dans certains
endroits dans certains territoires ça
fonctionne bien en france dans d'autres
territoires c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et il faut qu'on soit capable
de jouer de ses atouts pour repartir
dans une démarche ambitieuse et
conquérante mais en faire des abonnés
par rapport encore une fois aux italiens
aux espagnols aux allemands mon sujet il
est là en fait oui mais en même temps
sur certains sujets reprenons le cas
d'airbus un exemple extraordinaire de
compas de collaboration franco-allemande
qui permet de créer un leader européen
qui est en train de devenir l'acteur
dominant il du marché de l'aviation
commerciale regardons ce qui est en
train de se passer sur l'industrie
automobile ford transformation véhicules
électriques tout d'un coup une idée
gerland disons mais on peut pas passer à
côté des sujets des batteries et parce
qu'effectivement dans un véhicule
électrique une part importante de laval
airbus de avait fait est fait autour des
batteries et alors c'est pas un airbus
de la batterie mais c'est de très
nombreux projets aujourd'hui qui se
localise sur notre territoire et la
france est plutôt bien placé aujourd'hui
pour accueillir un certain nombre de ces
projets pour fabriquer ce composant
essentiel de la voiture de demain donc
il y a décidé d'attribuer viennent
d'asie et en asie corée chine jacques à
manger de 90% absolument mais là il ya
eu cette idée quand même temps que la
voiture électrique se développe est elle
se développe du fait de normes qui
seront imposées par par l'europe
on allait s'attaquer à ce sujet et faire
en sorte de le localiser en europe une
production de batteries c'est un symbole
qui est fort et je crois qu'il faut que
vous inscrire que j'essaye de pousser au
changement il y a un avenir pour
l'industrie la vision d'une société post
industrielle que certains de mes
collègues d'ailleurs industriels ont pu
porter à 700 usines effectivement un
trône alcatel les rebelles disant ceux
de ma société son suicide non c'est pas
la réalité la réalité c'est une société
dans laquelle on a besoin d' usine pour
fabriquer les produits de demain et puis
on est aujourd'hui en europe face à un
enjeu majeur qui est la transition
énergétique et là je pense qu'il ya une
opportunité massif pour l'industrie
française et européenne c'est juste
après il faut aussi admettre qu'on a un
problème de compétence à le coût du
travail on a parlé anglais avec un peu
rapidement ce que c'est un sujet qui est
qui est assez bien connus mais on a
promis de compétences aussi en france on
manque d'ingénieurs on n'a pas ces
techniciens et sa touche en fait tous
les métiers l'industrie qui sont
tensions voire en pénurie et là on se
dit qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'il faut
qui plus d'étudiants qu'il fasse plus de
cursus scientifiques les garçons et les
filles aussi d'ailleurs non alors votre
question résume bien la fin résume un
groupe comme angie il a besoin de
techniciens pour faire pour entretenir
des installations de production
d'énergie ou de chauffage ou d'air
conditionné et il a besoin d'ingénieurs
de très haut niveau pour développer des
projets innovants dans l'ensemble de
cette chaîne on a des difficultés de
recrutement aujourd'hui on cherche à y
apporter des réponses pour pour les pour
les métiers de technicien s'est souvent
nous qui prenons l'initiative de créer
des centres de formation d'apprentis des
centres de formation en alternance qui
permet d'attirer des jeunes et de les
former vers ces métiers dans lesquels il
ya des opportunités et pour ce qui est
des ingénieurs oui nous avons
aujourd'hui des difficultés à attirer
les meilleurs dans des cursus
scientifique et technique commandant ils
ont dit aux jeunes de travailler dans
l'industrie
c'est un petit peu ce que j'ai essayé de
faire très très modestement en écrivant
ce en écrivant ce petit essai et en
partageant ses idées avec où on les
mobilise en leur expliquant que
l'industrie à une partie des réponses
aux enjeux de la planète d'aujourd'hui
je pense que le canton parle changement
climatique au jour donné du sens c'est
pour quand on parle changement
climatique aujourd'hui un jeune je vois
avec mes deux filles
on en voit on les réveille on leur dit
on leur montre qu'il ya effectivement
quelque chose à faire on leur montre que
travailler dans l'entreprise travaillait
dans l'industrie a du sens et permettent
contribuer à répondre à ces défis et je
crois qu'il faut que l'industrie
s'expriment les industriels s'exprime
avec force pour attirer les meilleurs
talents chez eux après il faut pas nier
que beaucoup de choses ont été faites du
point de vue politique par les autorités
par les pouvoirs publics ces dernières
années pour l'industriel ces baisses
d'impôts de production 10 milliards
d'euros beaucoup on réclame 30 ou 40
après je passerai le déficit public le
permettent mais ça notre sujet mais il
ya eu la réforme de la formation
professionnelle de l'apprentissage tout
ça va dans le bon sens même si c'est
tardif tout ça va dans le bon sens quand
je on a vraiment franchi une étape sur
l'apprentissage là aujourd'hui les le
nombre de jeunes en formation en
alternance est en train d'exploser et ça
c'est très bien il faut qu'on continue
son seuil à tous les niveaux de niveau
technicien jusqu'à des niveaux de
formation supérieure réforme de la
formation professionnelle très utile
impôts de production je pense que là
aussi on a franchi une étape même s'il
reste beaucoup de choses à faire pour
retrouver tout simplement la parité avec
eux la parité avec certains de nos
concurrents européens il faut aussi bien
sûr rester attractif que le site france
reste attractif il est de plus en plus
pour le coup dans les enquêtes mais
quand on voit le géant américain des
semi-conducteurs qui veut fabriquer en
europe pour 30 milliards d'euros des
puces électroniques des semi conducteurs
des chips comme on dit en anglais y met
son usine en allemagne il met son
laboratoire de recherche en france nous
on a un peu le lot de consolation et
finalement la production la partie
industrielle de production se retrouve
en allemagne alors je crois pas que la
recherche soit le lot de consolation au
contraire un serment quelque chose qui
est très important et c'est vrai que la
france à la fois par la qualité des
compétences je disais tout à l'heure
mais l'usiné là bas l'usiné là bas pas
assez d'ingénieurs mais beaucoup
d'ingénieurs de très très haut niveau un
système de crédit d'impôt recherche qui
est particulièrement attractif ça ça
attire les sounders mais il faut que les
usines deviennent aussi chez nous
certaines viennent chez nous on a vu
beaucoup de projets annoncés c'est
annoncées ces derniers mois qui montre
que le site france retrouve de
l'attractivité on peut pas gagner tous
les projets mais il faut qu'on se batte
et qu'on montre à nos collègues
industriels étrangers mais aussi aux
grands comptes français que le site
france est un site attractif aujourd'hui
l'europe vous l'avez évoqué un jean
pierre clamadieu quitte à l'avant garde
de cette transition énergétique on a des
cartes à jouer de l'industrie française
doit en profiter à l'image de ce qu'a
fait angie mais pas seulement alors
qu'elle est en temps je les jeunes les
u17 en même temps
les hélices et les mâts des éoliennes ne
sont pas fabriqués en france alors ça
c'est non non c'est cet accord j'ai
aujourd'hui sur l'éolien marin en
particulier on a fait un gros effort
pour que l'industrialisation sur terre
de ses produits pour que
l'industrialisation de ses produits
puissent se faire effectivement pu se
faire effectivement france a une carte à
jouer en tout cas il ya une carte à
jouer et est à nouveau ne posons pas la
france et les autres pays européens je
pense que c'est vraiment la plaque
européenne qui a vocation à redevenir un
acteur majeur en matière industrielle
entre les différentes régions du monde
et quand on parle projet moi y'a un
sujet que j'ai vraiment qui me tient
très à coeur assez l'hydrogène je suis
persuadé que dans la transition
énergétique qu'engage l'europe
aujourd'hui l'hydrogène un rôle
essentiel à jouer parce que c'est une
sorte de second fluide énergétique aux
côtés de l'électricité mais qui a des
caractéristiques particulières très
intéressante le fait qu'ils se stoppe
très facilement le fait que c'est un gaz
donc une forte densité d hydrogène bien
sûr l'hydrogène verts il est produit à
partir d'électricité renouvelable il
peut être consommé dans des
installations industrielles
il peut être consommé dans des moyens de
transport qui vont du train à l'avion en
passant par le bateau houleux où le
poids lourd et l'europe pourrait être le
premier la première région du monde à
développer un réseau de production de
transport de stockage est distinct du
classement du thon rouge jaune vert avec
une place importante pour la france il y
à des groupes comme angie qui ont des
installations de stockage de gaz qui
pourraient être utilisés pour ce qu'est
d'hydrogène il y à des canalisations
bien sûr qui pourrait contribuer à un
axe européen hors sud sur ce sujet et
puis il ya des compétences et des savoir
faire airbus travaille aujourd'hui sur
un avion à hydrogène la sncf s'intéresse
à l'hydrogène comme substitut au diesel
pour c'est pour ces engins de pour ses
engins de de manoeuvre et
et ceux qui tirent des trains sur les
lignes qui ne sont pas électrifiés
cma-cgm sur le maritime est aussi très
en avance dans la réflexion sur ces
sujets ce sont des opportunités la
relance et d'une carte à jouer sur ce
sujet mais sur bien d'autres l'airbus
des batteries on en parlait tout à
l'heure le développement de technologies
moi j'étais impressionné par
l'investissement d'arcelormittal en
france pour fabriquer de l'acier par un
procédé qu'on appelle de réduction
directe donc en utilisant d'ailleurs là
aussi que l'hydrogène mais sans émission
de co2 associées il y a énormément de
projets créateurs d'aujourd'hui ainsi
son créateur d'emplois qui sont
créateurs d'emplois parce que pour un
emploi industriel j'ai pu chiffres en
tête ces trois ou quatre mais on est à
trois quatre emplois induits voilà en
fait l'emploi industriel il a un
caractère très structurant entendu dire
dès le début d'ailleurs ça oui et j'ai
fait une petite tribune il ya quelques
semaines pour montrer que dans le bassin
d'emploi de dunkerque dunkerque on a
l'image effectivement d'un tamassa
d'emploi qui a beaucoup souffert dans la
période de désindustrialisation
des années des années 80 sur dunkerque
investissements massifs annoncés dans
les batteries plusieurs milliers
d'emplois à la clé arcelormittal il
investit lui plusieurs milliards d'euros
pour transformer son aciérie en acier
réduction directe et angie vient avec un
projet de production d'hydrogène et puis
intéressant en combinaison avec
arcelormittal est un acteur américain
produit produisons un projet pour
produire ce qu'on appelle des i fiul
c'est à dire des carburants complètement
décarbonés en utilisant de l'hydrogène
et du co2 produit par arcelormittal et
ça c'est des projets qui font d'une zone
comme celle de dunkerque une zone
d'expérimentation de ce qu'est la
transition énergétique et son impact
concret dans la création d'emplois il ya
une amitié nucléaire intéressante
opportunité tout comme digital quand on
vous lit on comprend que le digital
c'est aussi une chance pour l'industrie
alors le digital est essentiel pour
l'industrie le digital est une vous
l'avait expérimenté technologies
digitales les technologies liées aux
données est quelque chose qui est en
train de changer la donne dans
l'industrie je le raconte d'ailleurs dit
effectivement dans mon petit livre au
début j'étais un meuble chimiste chez
solvay un peu sceptique ambiance ça fait
longtemps qu'on utilise des calculateurs
qui permet de piloter nos procédés et
puis un jour des jeunes ingénieurs sont
venus me rencontrer au hasard d'une
visite et me dire
on pourrait vraiment faire beaucoup plus
si vous vous donniez un tout petit peu
de moyens on a identifié des logiciels
des algorithmes comme on dit qui
permettrait de mieux piloter nos outils
je leur ai dit pourquoi pas et j'ai été
étonné du résultat dire qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui il ya des algorithmes qui
tournait avant sur des médias
calculateur et donc était pas du tout
accessible en milieu industriel qui
tourne aujourd'hui sur des ordinateurs
qui ont des puissances de calcul qui
sont accessibles à tous qui permettent
de bien mieux gérer nos outils
industriels je le vois aujourd'hui chez
angie ou nos parcs de renouvelables par
exemple aux parcs éoliens sont eux
bénéficient eux aussi de ce que le big
data pour reprendre la terminologie
qu'on emploie souvent peut apporter en
optimisation de fonctionnement et donc
oui digital transition énergétique et
industrie ça va vraiment très bien envie
qu'elle place là-dedans dans
l'écosystème pour les start up elles
sont là aussi très utiles les
algorithmes que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure que mes ingénieurs de solvay ont
utilisé il était promise été développé
par une start up américaine les start up
c'est un moyen de développement très
rapide et efficace c'est une source
d'inspiration pour les entreprises on a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui créent ici ou
là dans leurs sièges sociaux des petits
coins start up dans lesquels on essaie
de reproduire à une échelle à une
échelle modeste là l'efficacité et la
rapidité du travail qu'on est capable de
faire dans une dans une start up et je
pense que ces écosystèmes
c'est ce qu'ils permettent à l'industrie
de se renforcer et de se développer donc
on finit là dessus il ya de nombreuses
raisons de croire au renouveau de
l'industrie française même si encore une
fois par dans les chiffres macro sont
peu sont peu encourageants on cesse tout
juste de détruire les anciennes vouziers
en france je pense que les chiffres
macro immonde qu'on est en train de
toucher le fond de la leçon de l'arrivée
seconde s'anime et moi je suis convaincu
qu'on est en train de repartir qu'on
voit des signaux concrets qui montrent
qu'on repart je pense qu'il faut de
l'ambition je pense qu'il faut des
entrepreneurs dans les grands groupes
dans les petites structures comme les
start up je pense qu'il faut aussi des
pouvoirs publics qui nous guident les
grands projets que j'évoquais sur la
transition énergétique et climat lien
ces deux font plaisir d'ailleurs y ait
assez d'argent public d'investissement
aujourd'hui je serais quel sujet je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup d'investissement
ya de l'argent public il ya beaucoup
d'argent privé qui est prête à
s'investir sur des projets qui font sens
mais il nous faut un récit comme on dit
il nous faut une ambition il faut des
projets et ceci conduit à naturellement
aligner les ressources et les ambitions
et oui moi je suis convaincu qu'il ya un
avenir pour l'industrie française dans
l'europe raisonnons europe c'est
vraiment l'échelle pertinente pour
pouvoir jouer dans la compétition
mondiale allez merci être passés nous
voir à jean pierre clamadieu d'enclos
président dj mercière
[Musique]